Speaker 1: One more January six story that
I want to go over.
It is now being reported that Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham allegedly told police on January
6th about the rioters.
You've got guns, use them, you've got guns.
Use them now.
Why would we care about this?
There's actually two reasons which I will
tell you in a moment.
Let's first look at a report about this that
aired on CNN.
Speaker 2: Graham, according to your report,
yelled at the Senate sergeant at arms.
What are you doing?
Take back the Senate.
You've got guns.
Use them.
The South Carolina senator was adamant we
give you guns for a reason.
He repeated, Use them.
Another stark contrast to show how the Republican
Party, you know, they've been whitewashing
Jan. six ever since that day.
But at that time, somebody like Lindsey Graham
was obviously very afraid of what was going
on and was calling on law enforcement there
to resort to some very extreme measures.
Speaker 1: So there's a few really important
and interesting things here.
First of all, a lot of these Republicans who
in retrospect claim January six wasn't that
bad.
We weren't really that much at risk, et cetera.
Leaking, leaking, leaking, drip, drip, drip.
We're figuring out their actions and their
words.
Both spoke to the degree of insanity that
took place on that day.
Give you an example, Congressman Mo Brooks,
we found out, wore body armor that day.
Why do you wear body armor unless you expect
things to get really crazy now?
Mo Brooks has since said, My wife wanted me
to wear it.
But why did your wife think that there was
going to be fine?
I mean, it's not really an explanation that
takes Mo Brooks out of knowing in advance
that there was a real potential for violence,
as one example.
Now we have Lindsey Graham, Lindsey Graham,
who has downplayed everything.
Is it?
Listen, some people acted inappropriately,
but most of what happened was constitutionally
protected speech and speech alone, et cetera,
et cetera.
He was afraid enough that he was telling police
officers to start shooting protesters.
And the story that they tell in retrospect
clearly doesn't match up with their actions
on that day, nor does it match up with the
words that are now being ascribed to them.
There's a good Newsweek article about this,
which says Senator Lindsey Graham reportedly
called for rioters to be shot as lawmakers
were forced to evacuate the Senate chamber
on January 6th.
The Washington Post Sunday published the results
of a lengthy investigation reconstructing
what happened before, during and after the
riot.
The second part, titled Bloodshed, goes into
detail about how then Vice President Mike
Pence and members of Congress were evacuated,
as we know, according to the Post.
Graham, a Republican from South Carolina,
was furious that senators were forced to flee
their own chamber.
He yelled that the sergeant at arms and earned
urged him to shoot rioters in the mob.
The newspaper reported, citing a Republican
senator with knowledge of the exchange.
What are you doing?
Take back the Senate.
You've got guns.
Use them.
We give you guns for a reason.
Immediately after the riot, Graham turned
against Donald Trump and refused to join his
GOP colleagues in objecting to the certification
of Biden's win.
Trump and I, we've had a hell of a journey.
I hate to end it this way.
Oh my God, I hate it.
From my point of view, he's been a consequential
president, but today all I can say is count
me out.
Enough is enough.
But he soon fell back in line defending Trump
as he was impeached a historic second time
over the Capitol insurrection earlier this
year.
Graham insisted Trump remains the most popular
Republican in the country and is essential
to the GOP going forward.
To try to erase Donald Trump from the Republican
Party is insane, and the people who try to
erase him are going to wind up getting erased.
It's impossible for this party to move forward
without President Trump being its leader because
the people who are conservatives have chosen
him as their leader.
So when we think about what happened on January
six and as we learn more about it and we learn
about who knew what, when and what were people
expecting at different points in time, remember
that their actions and their words on that
day tell us much more than their words today.
It was no big deal.
These were mostly peaceful protests.
Etc..
Lindsey Graham saying shoot the protesters.
Mo Brooks wearing body armor, et cetera, et
cetera, they've been lying all along in the
aftermath of January six.
That belief that understanding just as reinforced
more and more with every passing day, we're
going to take a quick break.
I have so much more to cover today.
For more on all of today's stories, make sure
you're following us on Instagram at David
Pakman show and you can follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.